for me the difference playing it is so
surreal it's so resonant
[Music]
so satisfying
hey friends I'm here today at the
beautiful showroom of Marshall brene the
Fantastic guitar luthier we're
conducting a really fun experiment so I
am holding the first as far as I know
first ever classical guitar modern
classical guitar strung uh or fretted I
should say with gut Frets just like a
loot or a baroque guitar would have been
this is a fun experiment that we decided
to do and we made a whole video about
doing this which you can check out here
and while I'm here I couldn't resist the
opportunity to teach you all about one
of the most fascinating Topics in music
theory that I'm aware which is called
temperaments our alternate historical
tuning systems now that this classical
guitar has got Frets we can actually
move them to tune in these adjusted
temperaments so I'm going to play some
classical guitar pieces that you've
probably only ever heard in equal
temperament and we're going to see how
it sounds
foreign
now before we take these gut Frets and
start sliding them around to explore
some historical temperaments just a
quick little history lesson about what
our temperaments in the first place you
might not know this but we're all
actually playing in a very specific
temperament called equal temperament
it's just become the ubiquitous accepted
tuning system at least in the West
foreign
and what this means is we have a system
here of 12 notes per octave so from E to
e we can divide we have divided that
octave into 12 even half steps
[Music]
and every single one of those half steps
or semitones is equally divided so
everything you could say is equally Out
Of Tune but the beauty of the system and
I think why it became standardized is
because it allows you to play in all
keys and then all keys sound the same
historically if we go to the Renaissance
or broke period guitars and loots have
these tied on gut Frets so the gut Frets
are the same material as the gut strings
the historical strings and because
they're tied on you can move them and
tune in these alternate tuning systems
which don't divide that octave into 12
equal half steps or semitones we can
compromise we can make one higher when
lower and therefore play in certain Keys
more into so let's play now and teach
you how to hear in these really cool
historical temperaments now just a word
about the setup I have going on here if
you didn't already watch the other video
which you should we've tied on gut Frets
to this classical guitar which is being
built for a client and at a certain
point we can't tie on more Frets because
we run into this piece here called the
heel so I've had to tape on normally
those be glued on Frets that would go
onto the actual body of the instrument
so this isn't the best looking setup
today but this instrument was never
meant to have good friends okay let's
hear what these beautiful temperaments
sound like let's start with our equally
tempered D major chord
a chord that all of us should know here
it is an equal temperament
[Music]
and here it is in a temperament called
quarter comma mean tone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as you can actually physically see the
Frets are quite unequal
some are spaced very far away and some
are very close essentially the first
fret has been raised the second fret
lower to the third fret race the fourth
fret lower it's basically a system of
compromising right some things go up
some things go down so we can play in
certain Keys more in tune so I really
hope you can appreciate
just how gorgeous that D major chord in
mean tone sounds
foreign
[Music]
the reason it sounds so pure is because
the major third the distance between D
and F sharp is a pure major third now as
opposed to equal temperament which was
actually quite sharp the distance was
high in the Fret you can actually
physically see uh here because this this
guitar has slots for Frets you can see
how far I've moved it's like two
millimeters down so that that note was
quite a bit painful and sharp
foreign
[Music]
now I know what you might be thinking
wait a minute this sounds so beautiful
and I hope you can appreciate how
beautiful and pure this sounds you might
be thinking at this point if this sounds
so good why wouldn't you do this all the
time why ever play an equal temperament
well this is why this is what an E flat
major chord sounds like
[Music]
oh
it's very painful you won't hear any
chords in equal temperament
sound that bad but how can the E flat
major chord sounds so bad when the chord
just next to it
sounds like heaven well to learn why we
have to understand the concept of n
harmonic notes if we visualize a
keyboard there are white keys and Black
Keys the white keys are simple to
remember because they're just a b c d e
f g there are no Sharps and flats but
the Black Keys to understand those we
have to understand the concept of Sharps
and flats so if we go to the key just to
the right of C we have C sharp or d flat
it's called both of those names
simultaneously why is that it's because
to Sharp something means to raise it by
one semitone or on a piano one key to
the right however if you're starting on
the note D and you say play D flat a
flat means to lower a note by a semitone
or one key on the piano therefore that
key is simultaneously C sharp and d flat
and in modern music where we use equal
temperament we just have to kind of get
used to this musicians have to know
depending on the context I might call
this a C sharp and I might call it a d
flat however when you are playing with
these unequal temperaments these early
temperaments you cannot simply play a d
sharp when you're supposed to play an E
flat because it'll sound like this
it's not the same note essentially the
sharps are lowered and the flats are
pushed higher and that's what allows us
to play Super in tune some of the time
so here we can really tell E flat is
quite high and this is normally on a
guitar supposed to be E flat but it's
low
I can make it sharp
there now that now that the same note
but listen to how far I had to raise
this is E flat
and that's a D sharp E flat D sharp
they're not the same pitch so this
temperament system means that we are
limited to specific Keys sounding
fantastic better than usual another key
is sounding terribly wrong today's video
is brought to you by classical guitar
Pro that's my brand new online classical
guitar chords which is six hours 53
videos it's a whole curriculum designed
to teach you what you would normally
learn in the first six months to a year
of classical guitar lessons so if you
want to learn classical guitar but are
stuck struggling reading music or
struggling to learn the techniques check
out classicalguitara dashpro.com to
learn more let's now play some classical
guitar music and have some fun using
these temperaments we'll start with a
study by Fernando sore now I should
mention these pieces I'm going to play
weren't meant to be played in
temperaments soar played an equal
temperament because he had a fixed fret
guitar we're just having some fun today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now that piece really worked beautifully
and I knew it was going to work because
it's in C major and C major is a great
key for quarter common mean tone but
there's no way this piece would have
worked if it was in C sharp major
beautiful
now we're going to play some more pieces
but to do so I'm going to need to teach
you another cool little trick one of the
things that players did with gut Frets
in the Renaissance in the broke period
is they added tiny little extra pieces
of gut glued or taped on to the
fretboard to create the difference
between those and harmonic notes so I
have this little piece of gut that I've
cut out here and I have a piece of tape
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
tape it on the fretboard and create
different options for notes so now as
you can see here I've taped on this
little mini fret and the mini fret is so
cool it's called the tostino and a
tostino allows you to play either the
lower part of the note or the upper part
of the note that means I can play a G
sharp or an A flat
to hear how the a flat is higher
and the g g sharp lower now this is so
cool because what it means is when I
play an E major chord I
have a beautifully pure E major chord
because that G sharp which is the major
third that an equal type
now I've literally put a lower fret
which means it's the right pitch
beautiful listen now to when I
accidentally spell it wrong and I play e
and the a flat that's the wrong note
it's supposed to be a G sharp but on a
piano you would think of it the same way
I just think this is so cool on all my
early instruments I used these and I
show up for you know an early music gig
and I have to know what temperament
we're in and I put on little tostini if
I need to I think it's just such a cool
thing to work with those in a harmonic
notes so now I have my lip tostino I can
play really good E major chords so let's
try this little Prelude by aguado first
in equal temperament
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for me the difference playing it is so
surreal it's so resonant
[Music]
I love that sound
it's so satisfying let's try a famous
Etude by karkazzi this is Etude number
seven first and equal
[Music]
let's try some taraga this is targa's
lagrima which is also in E Major
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this one didn't quite work some of the
chords sounded gorgeous to me that E
major chord sounds beautiful beautiful
third
gorgeous but I think
[Music]
even though beautiful chords like that
exists wonderful
nice
yuck so why doesn't this chord work
it's because it's a snapshot major chord
and I'm playing an a sharp supposed to
be playing an a sharp but this is
actually a B flat in this temperament so
it's ugly so unfortunately no longer I
guess in mean tone you know just because
this is a historical temperament doesn't
mean that I can only play historical
music uh I'm sure you could play a lot
of pop music in mean tone temperament
and it would sound great
[Music]
foreign
and that's gonna be it for today's video
If you enjoyed this free educational
video please do consider subscribing and
maybe even supporting my patreon where
you can get lots of extra guitar tips
and behind the scenes of what's going on
in my life if you missed the video where
Marshall brene and I put got Frets on
this guitar please do check that out and
if you want to go even deeper into this
idea of temperaments I strongly
recommend you check out the YouTube
channel early music sources they have
several videos on the topic and the
whole channel is really fantastic and if
you're a reader I strongly recommend how
equal temperament ruined Harmony by raw
Stefan thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]